welcome welcome to hills of colleges
Washington DC campus I'm Matthew
Spalding the vice president the college
back here in Washington C and also the
Dean of our new Van Andel Graduate
School of Government and I'm here this
evening we were here this evening with a
great friend of mine and a wonderful
scholar Mt slays Amity was previously at
The Wall Street Journal editorial board
and publish a weekly column and wrote a
great book in 1999 called the greedy
hand where I first met her we had her
head her do something for that book
she's written a very important book on
the New Deal
The Forgotten man a new history of the
Great Depression of which there's a
graphic a graphic version which I have
not seen I have to say and then a book
which is a personal favorite only those
are great works which came to my
attention wonderfully titled just
Coolidge which she wrote in 2013 and
she's on the Calvin Coolidge
Presidential Foundation Board which I'm
a big fan of so we have a number of
things in common but tonight we're going
to talk about her new book which is the
Great Society a new history which is
just out and we have copies of here for
all of you to buy and I have been
reading it and enjoying it immensely
especially given the connection between
that book in your previous book on the
New Deal and I'm struck as I've always
been struck about how so many of the
questions we deal with today health care
education poverty standards of living
these are issues that come out of the
Great Society but you seem to be saying
it's not that great indeed it might have
had some problems I know and so I want
to start with some general questions
about about the book but also about that
period because it turns out there's a
lot of things we can learn from studying
that period that might be extremely
applicable today so start off off by
what do we how should we if we're
looking back in history how should we
look at what is the Great Society how
should we perceive that as a thing what
a great society I think you might have
seen this morning that one of the
presidential candidates Mike Bloomberg
said it was time for a war on poverty so
that's that's a phrase from the Great
Society I think you always start like
with what I would just stop and say I'm
very glad to be here I'm very impressed
with Hillsdale a new graduate school and
dr. Spaulding and the Van Andel lecture
hall and school what an achievement
this is presence that was not here
before is here and very central no one
and very admirable so what do we learn
in school though maybe not
Hillsdale but what do we generally learn
in school about the Great Society in the
60s well if you the 60s are taught non
logically that's the first thing to say
so when you hear about the 60s it's
usually sort of tries to replicate the
Kaleidoscope maybe the the drug-related
experience so they'll be loud music
Woodstock napalm tragedy hippies Nixon
looking bereaved and resentful and so
it's almost hard to get a logical
picture certainly it's hard to get a
chronology at the period from the way
it's taught and that's a separate
problem to the problems of earlier
periods where for whatever sins are
contained in earlier tellings of earlier
periods they are usually chronological
and man is chronological we need that
thematic is very difficult for us to
retain or analyze it's or it's sort of
pre analyzed so that's the problem with
the history of the Great Society the
biggest problem is not left-right sees
me or where you are and the Vietnam War
when you switched it's that it's taught
more with emotion and kaleidoscope than
with logic to me so I said well what is
this period in the 1930s we had the New
Deal and what is Great Society it sounds
as ambitious as new
and it was in fact more ambitious
because the New Deal took place in a
time of genuine economic emergency if
one in four is unemployed that's a real
problem and people have to come up with
an answer and Franklin Roosevelt before
him Herbert Hoover did and we may not
like the answer and have had another
that we would have liked to have applied
in 1932 or 33 but there's the
unavoidable fact of the national
emergency this is a different story
because we were actually doing pretty
well in the early sixties everything
seemed to be getting better in every way
the 50s were a pretty good decade
everything seemed to me get getting
better in every way and we'll come back
to this Matthew but you know that
poverty went down dramatically if you
want to make war on poverty in the 1950s
basically because of economic growth so
there were what what do you give what's
the thing you give a poor person more
than anything else that he wants a job
right and so the fifties turned out to
be a great decade with jobs even
sometimes with benefits and we thought
oh well given how strong we are and that
were a superpower and all let's just
just clean up the rest of our little
problems cure poverty as Franklin
Roosevelt said and I remember the writer
Norman Podhoretz said we all thought
poverty could be cured this was just
after World War two for those who had
fought in World War two a kind of
mopping up action domestic because what
if you can win Europe or to feech a pan
of course you can help poor people and
all will be better that was the very
ambitious attitude in the early sixties
yeah there's there's a great chart in
the back of the book showing the decline
even strict very small for you but
showing that the decline of the rate of
poverty but then it kind of flattens out
after that that's right yeah so and I
want to mention here John Cogan of
Hoover who were at a fantastic book
called the high cost good potential good
intentions I think any
way it's all data and it's all true so
he also gets at this point we did not
cure poverty even though Franklin
Roosevelt hope we might and Lyndon
Johnson swore we would we may have
brought it down a bit at first when the
Great Society started and you look at
the chart you see poverty going down
sort of as fast and you can look at the
the points underlying the PowerPoint and
decide as it did in the 1950s and then
poverty by the official definition
established by our government leveled
off at ten percent a little more and
it's still there so curing poverty
didn't happen that was the promise of
the Great Society and it didn't happen
that's the main thing and I'm really
happy to have the framers here instead
of a power so so you've you've all
really to the compared spend the Great
Society and the New Deal but let's
broaden that a bit and look at the
various we're gonna call waves of
liberalism in the twentieth century
because the other one we have to add to
that is the early progressive movement
and it strikes me that it might be that
the Great Society has actually more
similarities to the early progressives
there was a sense I mean there was a
sense that somehow they could fix things
and and through expertise and more
government than Bureau what are you
putting the Great Society in this larger
motif of what modern liberalism and did
over the twentieth century well we used
to think that progressive social workers
worked we're in this state's the lady
from the state of Missouri or from the
county came to your house and said
whatever she had to say they might be
funded by the federal government in part
but it came from the state so early
progressivism the kind that inspired
Theodore Roosevelt was in the state of
Massachusetts in the state of New York
and that's where the progressives came
from we never imagined we would be
running the Social Work business from
Washington Eve
in times of prosperity most of us didn't
anyhow
so what happened in the early 1960s as
we said forget the states the federal
government needs to do this only the
federal government could do it and the
book opens actually with Michael
Harrington who was a socialist didn't
work for Moscow was just what was wrong
with these Socialists was not that they
were traitors it was that they were
wrong about their philosophy I did more
a nice man kind of an early JD Vance he
focused on Hillbillies they had a
problem some of that was social let's
figure that out alcohol troubles you
know and wrote a book called the other
America and that he said you know the
problem of America these deep-seated
problems of families and no food
sometimes are the wrong food or wrong
attitudes only the federal government is
capable of solving this only Washington
and there there was some consensus for
that even beginning under Kennedy
although Kennedy didn't get the
legislation and it only strengthened
only Washington can do this and remember
I'll just say one last thing a lot of
the men who were leading our country and
they were mostly men or what veterans so
most of the time this is before Vietnam
they had seen the federal government do
something good win a war and they might
have had a benefit or at one or the
other
when they came home they might have had
GI Bill they might have had subsidy for
housing that made entry and certainly
education and their people in this room
probably who but it was the attitude of
General Patrick Moynihan I never had to
pay for school because the government
took care of me I I trust the government
so they did trust the government the
federal government even very high level
of so so does the Great Society grow out
of the New Deal does it grow out of his
earlier roots is it something different
is there a shift in liberalism it's just
more does your wean it's just it's just
more ambitious but so it grows it's um I
mean you if you look for logic in it you
can find strands of logic depending on
the person right but what it was was a
general consensus that we had to do
something and with the print with the
imagine we're having a theater in the
background the bombs are going off all
the time offstage that's Vietnam right
offstage the battle rumbles and the
tension of sending four hundred five
hundred thousand people very suddenly
over to Asia is there so this idea we v
't Nam is a strand the progressive
impulse is a strand and another strand
is Lyndon Johnson's personal ambition
and lots of biographers Cairo most
recently have covered that but here's a
person who's the child of the New Deal
he was a Roosevelt pleaser very
effective congressman and it was said
there's a cartoon if you if if you want
something done quick in the New Deal you
get Lyndon Johnson the young man who
worked with youth in the state of Texas
and actually had to tell the farmers
they should plow over their crops and
that was economic logic you plow over
your crop and then you get money from
the federal government and the farmers
he had to convince the farmers and the
farmers were kind of dubious about that
and their mules were even more dubious
because the mules in Texas are trained
not to step on the little fledgling
plants right the whole experience of a
mule is not to step on plants and here
they were destroying something so Lyndon
Johnson did yeoman service to Franklin
Roosevelt executing a sometimes
nonsensical New Deal and he said when I
grow up I'm gonna finish Franklin
Roosevelt's agenda and I'm gonna finish
Harry Truman's agenda Harry Truman
wanted something like Medicare he hadn't
got it through Johnson was deeply proud
a proud man that he could get that
through but you want to think he's
ambitious so he plays to his strengths a
master of the Senate and III don't even
focus too much on Johnson in the book so
we'll stop there because he's just part
of this story but
that's that's him ambition and glory
perhaps even being greater than the New
Deal yeah one of your chart shows it how
the great site burns actually are larger
than the New Deal programs at a certain
point oh of course
yeah and if you have a chart which we
have in the back you will see that our
commitments to the Great Society cost
more than our commitments to New Deal
programs today that is papers our
lawmakers signed in the 60s committed us
to spending more today than even the New
Deal what's interesting is a walter
Lippmann the commentator wrote a
critique of the New Deal and it was
called a good society and one reason
walter Lippmann called it good was he
was signaling we should draw back from
the Superman ambition projects great but
you know great is wrong good but Johnson
liked great he was very proud of the
phrase he introduced it at the
University of Michigan in 1964 and if
not great then not at all was his
attitude right I think the phrase
greatest I was actually used by John
Dewey at one point section old
progressive phrase yes used by the
favorite Fabian socialist yeah so it
does actually have a history to it and
we will have great in England also means
big right it doesn't just mean high so
by Great Society actually in England
they meant a society that is networked
from town to town across the country
because before the railroad and the
telegraph towns were pretty isolated and
now we had a Great Society and the
newspapers began to come on the train in
the morning and we could hear what was
going on in London and practically
real-time that was what the Fabian
socialist imagined but they also
imagined right away that if a society is
great broad high it must have great
planners you can see that in the
language too and planning is a huge part
of Great Society ours and the sick side
that's why I mean but they did the sense
of going back to the early progressives
planning and expertise so the main
elements the Great Society correct me
from
right in in LBJ's his famous speech you
know healthcare health education the
environment or those domain really the
main areas city class some cities
country classroom and all those things
are why those and what was their
thinking on them well we did need some
environmental law or environmental habit
that was clear this was the era when you
couldn't drive through Gary because it
smelled too bad we did but it was it
wasn't had to roll up the window right
you that LBJ was very concerned about he
was very much of a car person you don't
see him walking a lot you know I think
America would be different if presidents
could walk down the street because he
was a vehicular president he an
amphibious car right so so so he liked
to beautify highways Lady Bird did along
with the beginning in the environment of
course Nixon did more and I include
Nixon in the Great Society that one of
the revisions of this book is that Nixon
is really just a follow-on to Johnson
the classroom Johnson was a school
teacher so that appealed to him and he
believed rightly I would say you would
to probably that education is much of
the answer to the ills poor families if
they know more they can earn more money
and okay so that's a one could say
that's a reasonable argument for those
three areas involvement how did it
become the the Great Society it was this
was this good intentions gone bad was
this the fatal conceit of planning was
this great ambition to get the federal
government involved was it to build the
consent would what's like well they it
was a power drive we want to stay in
power so we want to do more and more
impressive things so people will reelect
us that's the way the book ends with
Nixon seeking reelection but I'm not
sure what you're asking what I do say in
the book what I show in the book is
first they tried the war
on poverty and they had weird results
with that though the poverty law the
Economic Opportunity Act which created
the poverty office of sargent shriver
was seemed a fairly harmless law but
actually did quite a bit of harm what am
I thinking of many in this room are
concerned about federalism right what is
the state in charge of and can what is a
town in charge of that we had poverty in
American cities the mayors all had
poverty people maybe they didn't maybe
they called assistance not poverty but
they had poverty people many of the
mayors were Democrats they helped Lyndon
Johnson get elected in 1964 I'm thinking
here of Richard J Daley II and so when
Johnson declared war on poverty Richard
J Daley put all his poverty ideas in a
box big box mailed it to Washington
here's what I need money for that you
owe me because of what I gave you and
that is not what came out of the
poverties our office because of the
infatuation with reform and sometimes
social democratic or we would some it's
called them socialist ideas what came
out of that office was Sargent Shriver a
nice man brother-in-law of the late
president kind of noble hard to dislike
veteran created the Peace Corps running
this sent his own poverty people to the
towns and I'm thinking some of the
people in the room may have known of
that been part his own poverty people
and those poverty people believed in
community activism by which they didn't
by which they meant let's go to the town
hall and protest and try to get whatever
we need here it's we thought it would be
jobs but it ended up being housing
landlords and so on and the mayors could
not believe it they had elected Lyndon
Johnson and now Johnson's very own
people were bothering them in their
mayor office disturbing their day and
helping them with their problem of
poverty and in the book I tell the story
of Sam your D the mayor of Los Angeles
who said there will be riots in Los
Angeles unless you help me
President Johnson basically with my
poverty programs and he got into a
jurisdictional squabble with the poverty
office the mayor of Los Angeles versus
Sargent Shriver battement all spring and
the money that was promised didn't come
what's worse than no money money that
was promised and duska
what was worse than money that's never
promised money that was promised and and
that failure of your knee and it was his
failure to to bring the money he said
would be there to create hundreds and
hundreds of jobs for the youth of watts
contributed to the rage and watts along
with all the other factors that are more
famous such as the rough police
department and so on so sometimes when
you have multiple jurisdictions all you
have is jurisdictional lacunae and chaos
right and that often happened the other
mayor's also complain daily said you
know does the president know he's
sending mo n ey too can't remember what
equipment subversive some word like
subversives did he know that he didn't
we couldn't believe it that Johnson
would be so naive and I think Johnson
himself was kind of not really aware of
what Shriver was doing and he and
Shriver just wanted to get things done
fast and Johnson was pressuring him so
this was a great rivals one of the fools
of my book because he was a nice man who
did a naive thing and paid for it
terribly right right so let's let's try
to draw out some broader lessons here
and then we'll open up for questions
sure because there's a lot in your book
which I found fascinating about how
there was a push for a an idea wraps
because of idealism perhaps it was
politics but then there's often a
compromise or a push back by people like
Wilbur Mills or daniel patrick moynihan
but they could have got
get on that because it became took on a
life of its own is is a lesson here be
aware of idealism and government coming
together is it unintended consequences
is it don't compromise with idealists
and zealots I mean what's the larger be
where marginal increases and we know
that from government a little bit
because you're pointing out that so
Medicare was an add-on it was it was a
small add-on program that was agreed to
but then it became yeah in will vermin
what do we learn from that thank you
today this is what we're doing well and
debates writing today about what we
should do he was chairman he was known
as the powerful Wilbur Mills I think
until I was 10 I thought his name was
powerful you know the influential of the
Ways and Means Committee and Wilbur
Mills was a government expander but also
a pragmatist and he went along with
Medicare and kind of liked it because of
a lot of other trades he had going in
his complex business and then Medicare
costs a lot more than he thought it
would and he was embarrassed he had told
his constituents at home it wouldn't
cost this much and you know and he
became wise Everett Dirksen is the same
way Everett Dirksen supported Johnson on
civil rights which is very important to
the end of the filibuster of laws that
are very important that are also in this
period but when he came to some labor
laws Everett Dirksen said count me out I
this is too much support of organized
labor labor so I think if you would pick
a philosopher it would be Hayek and why
Hayek if you haven't heard of him I
don't know about him Hayek's folk of a
thing called the knowledge problem and
basically what it says is government is
insulated from knowledge by the
political process
you only get feedback at an election
every four years maybe every two years
every six years right and you only talk
to your friends in government whereas
the small business is in the market
every day and by night it knows whether
it did well with its product that day
and perhaps even how to adjust it so the
government was so in
from reality most of the time it
couldn't really figure out what it was
doing or what was wrong about that and
Hayek of course also has Road to Serfdom
and he's well and what Road to Serfdom
says is we're not living in Zeno's
paradox we you actually do get to surf
them even if you take little steps right
yeah it's not like oh we'll never get
there you actually get to Serfdom
because entrenched interest groups in
this case the silent majority the
Forgotten and once they have a benefit
as Thomas auld says they don't want to
let it go and when there are enough
entrenched groups it's very hard to
reform and I feel even silly saying this
in Washington where you know this better
than I let's let's open up for some
questions I know that there's some
microphones I believe go right there in
the back thank you very much for coming
to speak one of the things little may be
a little s now but certainly 10 or more
years ago folks who were alive either
who were of the so-called Silent
Generation or of the very older
so-called baby boomer generation will
often say if Vietnam hadn't happened the
Great Society would have worked it would
have been tremendous I have known myself
people alive from that time period were
activists or professors who told me that
and said if it had just been fully
funded and Vietnam hadn't happened
everything would have been great I'm
skeptical of that but I'm wondering how
you particularly answer that question I
would refer to you the chart on page 440
or maybe 439 that's the answer
what people began to realize it Vietnam
is the great sort of excused story and
Vietnam did help to bring about some of
the more expansive bits of legislation
you could say the Great Society with the
butter pricier than Joyce chart yeah and
maybe 435 435 but what I'm saying is
maybe the Great Society would have been
just the good society without me
because you have to have something
really good at home that's the opposite
to what people are arguing with you and
second even in this 60s by the late 60s
people saw that the butter at home the
domestic programs were going to cost
more than the guns that line was crossed
I believe it's in early 70s 71 and even
today we have this fallacy that defense
cost so much when you look at the whole
budget which includes mandatory spending
defense does not cost so much it costs a
relatively small share of our economy
compared to history a period of the
Korean War so so this argument isn't
reality
and the reason for example that we had
the fiscal crisis of 1971 and the
stagflation and high interest rates of
the seventies is not mostly Vietnam it's
the Great Society and that that's very
interest you know that's they're
foreigners looked at the US and said
it's going kind of social-democratic
that's like us which means it's growth
advantage may be eroded its growth
advent the US had a growth advantage it
was a freer market than Europe that
growth advantage that gap between
Scandinavia and Michigan is narrowing in
terms of social costs and therefore the
US might not be so strong so there are
plenty of pieces of data that refute
your argument your friends argument yep
yes miss Lay's isn't that the case the
reason the Autopia nism of the Great
Society was a most unchallenged was
because there was a lack of faith in
civil society and especially even in the
Republican Party after Dwight Eisenhower
took the party over and Robert Taft died
of cancer in 1953 and in a khadeem to I
mean there were just a few marginal
people in 1953 Robert Nesbitt and
Russell Kirk each published classics the
quest for community and the conservative
tradition but they were considered
wackos and outside
the Austrian economist - but and and the
voter registration was two-and-a-half
Democratic to Republicans isn't isn't
this the reason why I Johnson & Johnson
was a master of the legislative process
that the the chance to commit the Great
Society even occurred that's a very
important question I used to have a
debate with jonathan alter of newsweek
and he would say before the New Deal
amedy there was nothing and before the
New Deal there was something it was just
local it was the italian-american burial
Society or the it was the County of X Y
Z and it's little Hospital led by there
was a David Beto as a beautiful book
about Tocqueville in America which I
always give to kids and all the little
weird institutions moose heart the
orphanage very right yes still there so
there was a contempt for Tocqueville
America it seemed quaint and old and it
was a terrible contempt because
Tocqueville still makes America the
little town I have a chapter on the
fragility of the municipality where
Tocqueville writes about the fragility
of the municipality can be it's like a
consumptive patient it could die anytime
that municipality because the big state
by which Tocqueville probably meant the
the county or the the state that is
state of Illinois Springfield Albany it
might step on it and or you know pull
the cord so so when you want to think
about tocqueville's America in this
period I have a long description of the
housing program at pruitt-igoe in st.
Louis and what they did to the
Tocqueville of downtown st. Louis which
very proud town maybe some of you are
from there with a very local strong
let's support each other tradition just
wrecked by urban renewal and bulldozers
and I will just say one last thing for
the middle class we had something of
Tocqueville in our housing funding
because we said we'll give middle-class
people subsidized mortgages
so they can settle in little communities
the new suburbs right and then they can
have a cul-de-sac and a car and their
children can play there and that they'll
build a new community and will fund that
the federal government that's also love
it Levitt time
that's for middle class paper for poor
people they can have Karl Marx and we'll
build big tall really ugly buildings in
the International style which we kind of
admire but tends to make people feel sad
and lonely and and we'll send them up in
elevators and in the halls they'll be
beat up by wayward children and there'll
be no commerce at all around them and
certainly and let's bulldoze the
churches around the edge right because
we're bulldozing the whole community so
Muslim churches go to in all the other
tocqueville institutions that happen to
have been there around we're the new
tall buildings go and at the end of the
book I described how after all the
successive waves of progressivism and
non Tocqueville ISM at st. Louise
pruitt-igoe they had to as in Chicago
blow it up wasn't one of the to go back
in the earlier point you made visit
there's a certain polish cos never about
you know one or the other in that in
those absolute ways it's very rarely
that kind of question right one of the
things the great site took advantage of
was a a natural American desire to try
to solve some of these problems poverty
to allow for growth and expansion in a
national economy right so they they they
drove right through that because you
know there there was a as the nation
grew and the economy grew and and it
became larger there was a need to solve
some of these problems they just thought
they could perfect it by using
Washington programs to do so when I was
writing it yeah so the quant a Great
Society we're ambitious its 1960
we're teenagers and we don't remember
World War two right the boomers were at
like the woke students now who say hey
boomer right the boomers were the
generational divide the rebellion
and they said we want to do something
great the only question is by what means
through the public sector or the private
sector
well we opted for the public sector and
what is the private sector it's the milk
cow that funds it and you know what if
you leave the private sector alone
enough it usually can fund a lot of
whatever you want to do with your Great
Society vision so in the book when I was
writing it I decided to tell the story
of three companies General Electric
Toyota which intervened suddenly in
Detroit and the company that became
Intel and these companies did social
things number one they created jobs
number two in Fairchild which is the
predecessor to Intel for example at a
factory on a Native American reservation
and became the greatest private sector
employer of Native Americans because the
this particular Native American group
worked with their hands did a lot of
handy work like weaving basically or
neat what we would call needlepoint and
making chips involves the same skills
plus a magnifying glass right so so they
the private sector can do more than we
think to solve social problems and that
was it but we opted for the public
sector of course one of the greatest
spokesmen for GE was well I tell the
stories a beginning the the they had an
actor who worked for GE who was kind of
old and not even that good a little bit
corny and he was hired to propagandize
for the free market and that was Reagan
so Reagan there he was he was a
middle-aged man now and he gave not just
50 or 100 but maybe a thousand speeches
about markets to the rubber chicken
circuit of the hundred plants of General
Electric because General Electric was
concerned that its workers didn't
understand that capitalism was fragile
and mmin it all was for naught I mean in
Chapter 1 because GE suffered a terrible
embarrassment its employees fixed prices
and deals with Westinghouse it was
described it's like a sports scandal for
America because people respected GE as
they respect baseball and it went down
in the world and they fired the actor
and they fired his boss LEM Boulware and
they got rid of all the little
propaganda mill programs and they
thought what a waste we screwed up and
but Reagan remembered and eventually
became a convert to these ideas he came
to believe in my markets a new buy
background a new dealer so that that
story is told so since you brought that
up I Reagan in his 1982 diary famously
writes the press is trying to paint me
as trying to undo the New Deal I remind
them I voted for FDR four times I'm
trying to undo the Great Society
it was LBJ's Warren party that led to
our present mess
very interesting I didn't I don't have
so so I mean the history is he saw the
Great Society as the enemy to be
defeated absolute history is history but
it's also characters they don't have to
be presidents they can be just the next
line so there was a book called best and
the brightest about the foolish errors
of arrogant men in the Vietnam War
planning the Vietnam War in the
execution the negotiation the
prosecution there's a domestic best and
the brightest that is a bunch of guys
who were so smart they thought they
could do this not just Sarge driver but
also Walter Reuther and where is Reagan
he's like the mayor's because he became
governor of California and he had lots
of things to do and the federal
government kept getting in the way and
there's a hilarious scene where the
governor's had a kind of way of vetoing
a federal project a poverty project but
it wasn't a really good veto
they could be overruled basically so he
was going to overrule something the
Nixon administration was doing which was
funding public interest lawyers and the
Nixon didn't want that because Nick
I knew in his heart that Reagan was just
as popular as he was Nixon right this is
very awkward moment and you have the
lawyers for Nixon and the president and
the lawyers for Reagan one of them was
at Mies in a room and and the scary
administration led by Frank Carlucci
said there's a kind of very
condescending Lee to the Reagan crowd
using a film metaphor because Reagan
would understand it right there's an a
movie where you blow this all up and we
blow you up and forgive me I don't have
the text here but something like that
and there's a b-movie when we make a
compromise and neither of us loses face
on this lawyers funded by Washington
thing and maybe will help you with your
welfare cutbacks which is your big pride
Governor Reagan and nice goes into
another room and presumably phones
Reagan comes back and says we take the B
movie and then Reagan I think he sent
Carlucci a bottle of an alcoholic
substance I believe it might have been
scotch
so that was Reagan he the governor he he
decided this it all worked out
it wasn't just scorch and burn right but
the welfare program became a model for
welfare reform later Reagan's own and
then also Clinton's right good
it's got fire here oh yeah yeah I miss
lays thank you for coming Christopher
Harris with unhyphenated America and I
said a quick question my family is
originally from Detroit and you know
Walter Williams has talked about how the
the effect of the Great Society on the
black family in particular you talk
about how the poverty was decreasing had
decreased dramatically proud of that and
I've talked to many of my family members
they say look everybody that they grew
up with my father 69 years old and
basically everybody they grew up with
had a mother and a father and a home I
mean you know there was a handful of
people who did not have a mother and a
father and a home and afterwards like
I'm sick I'm 46 you'll see the large
percentage of people in my generation
did not grow up with a mother and father
at home why do you think that the New
Deal didn't have such a destructive
effect on the
like family or families in general as
such as the great societies and on
families in general thank you great
question actually the the family
separation issue the the provide what
what the the most proximate thing to
which you refer is to get welfare money
you had to be a single parent and the
welfare money and then on top of that to
get subsidized housing so that was some
of that was pre Great Society it was
state welfare law for example which said
we won't support men who earned but will
support families with dependent children
and no worker mom so it was a perverse
outcome from a well-meaning plan and in
my description of pruitt-igoe this
housing project which was rather like
the housing projects in Detroit the dads
had to hide in the closet when the
social worker came because they would
lose not only the money but also the
family would the apartment if the dad
were discovered and where is the dad
supposed to go Oh far away and get a job
that was a huge factor which the Great
Society through the format of its
funding perpetuated and strengthened and
it wasn't just black families it was
white families as well I would add
another factor though I really don't
like her band renewal that was my note
said I'm paraphrasing move says urban
renewal is minority removal and when the
riots happened in Detroit it was said it
was the people who had been bulldoze out
of old neighborhoods which were not only
poor not only occasionally slums but
also lively and much-loved Bulls
bulldozed out of their homes to be put
in sterile vertical projects and they
were angry and sad they were displaced
in displaced they were displaced by
slavery then they were displaced when
they moved north and then they were
displaced again from that place where
they originally lived when they moved to
Detroit that's a lot of displacement for
for our family so I tried to describe
that in
the book and I very much appreciate your
raising that issue did write another
character in your book is daniel patrick
moynihan who of course wrote a report on
the black family and then was later
vilified tell us about him but the first
person in my lifetime I know about who
was ever canceled daniel patrick
moynihan
because he wrote a book trying to
describe trouble in a single-parent
family particularly maybe when the
father who departed or is infrequently
present is alcoholic that's been and by
the way that's Daniel Patrick Moynihan's
life he just happens to be white so his
father was not there and there were
other father's occasionally and and this
was problematic for the Moynihan's so he
tried to describe that question which
you just put your finger on and pretty
soon it became to seem condescending for
a white person to describe something
that what is supposed to be uniquely
black which it isn't and he was shut out
by the Democrats and so I spend a lot of
time on Moynihan and his humiliation and
loneliness because he was actually very
insightful guy who had a lot to
contribute to government and his revenge
was to come back working for Richard
Nixon and offer a program that sounds
very familiar today which is guaranteed
income for whites and blacks below a
certain income level but but the
cancelling of Moynihan by the world and
Cambridge Massachusetts is a bitter and
fiery thing to behold there's someone
over here yes sir thank you very much
for your talk tonight one question is so
at the very beginning you talked about
how the early progressives were very
much more focused on the states it's
very much more of a smaller level than
federal and it's saying it sounds to me
like later on its we were with the Great
Society that you see the progressive
thought take root in kind of that
federal portion Woodrow Wilson talks
very much in his writings about the idea
of a hive mind he talks about how
there's this kind of this general
aggregate or everything centralizes in
Washington
and to provide kind of an analogy a lot
of people provide how Lincoln almost
acts as a fulfillment for the American
Founding so in a similar way could you
say that if you want to think of the
progressive thought with Wilson as a as
a refounding or revolution could you say
almost that that fulfillment comes about
in the Great Society yes would you care
to elaborate but remember did you ever
read a god man at Yale by William F
Buckley I never read it because I wasn't
interested particularly in the God part
but what it's really the meat of it was
they changed the way they teach
economics in college gee-whiz we used to
teach about individuals and I don't know
the invisible hand and so on and now all
of a sudden it's all about planning so
that commenced this big see changing
universities right after World War Two
which meant 15 years worth of
undergraduates hadn't had been schooled
in this planning way of thinking so now
the grown-ups didn't know much about
free markets or care about them that
they knew about planning and so those
people were ready to take over around
1960 they had become the grownups and
the leaders yeah well in that in that
planning grows out of the philosophical
roots of the early progressives who
thought that progressive experts could
solve all problems right and what also
there's like a cumulative effect
planning upon planning yields perversity
oh we had that reform last year oh we
haven't this is the 17th definition of
child we've had in the tax code and each
one contradicts the other and five are
still yeah it also goes back to the
fellows point here which is they always
oh it didn't work because there was some
factor that was not right what's right
again well try it right this is like a
book about it with a bunch of
progressive waves with
and they get bigger and bigger and the
magnitudes of dollars get bigger because
of the very beginning Michael Harrington
hears from Sargent Shriver they're gonna
get a billion dollars for welfare and
and Michael Harrington says that's just
nickel and dimed we need more than a
billion and Sargent Shriver since I
don't know about you young man but I
never had a billion to spend before I
think it feels pretty big but of course
the numbers did go Harrington wise into
the magnet even had a few zeros so so
that conversation just not to be a spot
but it's the very beginning of the book
and she doesn't identify who the two
people are until you get several pages
into the conversation and it sounds
eerily like a conversation you might
hear today in the halls of Congress
about you know very large programs very
large idealistic ideas about what
government ought to be doing why did we
learn any of these lessons why are we
doing this again this well the motto of
the book which I will say I have heard
chanel Coco Chanel say but also other
important people
what is nothing is new it is just
forgotten where nothing is new it is
just forgotten grammar is a little
awkward but I still like it nothing is
new but it has just forgotten we forgot
the 70s which were the consequence well
they were forgettable dedicated worried
definitely forgettable so so what what
is this I try to explain the seventies
to myself and other people the 70s was a
period when we thought our houses would
be smaller than our parents and they
technically were at certain points and
we had two fewer bedrooms than we
actually needed because the interest
rate was 18% that it was it was a period
where we didn't think we would ever have
enough energy to heat our homes and you
know I I don't even want to write the
seventies because it's a little dark I
have to figure out a happy 70 those of
you who remember that
ratcheting down of expectation the
emphasis on scarcity is reminiscent of
the current environmental movement I
mean there was a philosopher named Paul
Ehrlich who actually believed there
should be a very heavy tax on diapers so
that people would have fewer babies and
also we should change the tax code no
child credit none of that and to
discourage reproduction because we
wouldn't be able to feed ourselves and
more importantly we were the world's
model and how about introducing the
vasectomy and and let's how about giving
a lot of incentives for that procedure
and and I find a very creepy looking
back particularly their hubris and of
course other countries took what we
recommended via our World Bank and mr.
McNamara and and did awful things with
their populations through thinking of in
India and the sterilizations that were
virtually forced upon people there as
part of our progressive ideal of
population reduction it's gonna cold
more questions go back there there's
what appear - thank you so my question
is it seems that with the Great Society
there is a certain appeal to nobility
there's a higher aim towards it at the
eradication of poverty so that's a very
idealistic sentiment but also a noble
one is there a way of introducing a
nobility into free-market economics that
simply isn't rooted in self-interest to
provide a sort of greater appeal that
would move folks in my generation and a
little younger than some of the people
here and allow them to it move forward
well reductive way I I think one thing
you're talking about is the
transactional nature of Silicon Valley
I'll never know the counterparty in this
deal I'm selling him X Y Z and I don't
care about it but that's not most of
Commerce most of free market is everyone
you meet you will
again every person you ever meet in your
life will remember the encounter with
you and how you handle the transaction
and were you kind and did you under
deliver or over deliver that's what I
want always tell students you think
you'll never see someone again you will
always see ever everyone again and
everyone will always remember what your
tie what color it was
or your scarf and where you polite or
did you talk to someone else and did you
cheat him
so there is an natural morality to
Commerce because when you sell something
to someone they remember that if you
cheated them m't life most of us avoid
bad airports because bad airports lie to
us they advertise a closed gate and then
we find we have to walk two miles to the
gate they say we have a boarding pass
and then we run seated right it's a so
so we know when we can to avoid bad
airports which are say say low trust low
trust places and we look for high trust
places where the airport is even nicer
than we thought and maybe it has free
coffee I think they have that in in
Toronto so you say I like that and
that's not socialism that's good
commerce right so so I think we have to
think about the kindness and the
morality and commerce and expose it
let's think of it this way eBay when we
were young people my age again we
wouldn't have believed that eBay could
work because you send your money off to
someone in another state who nobody you
know knows and he or she sends you back
more or less the thing you ordered right
more or less and sometimes it's a part
which you haven't inspected yourself
like a car part oh my gosh and it might
be flawed in some way where that other
person could say he technically sent you
a good thing but the thing is useless to
you and we might send $185 for a car
part if we're building a car
and yet most of the time eBay works most
of the time most of us are satisfied
with eBay and say well that is an
incredibly wonderful economy where the
people don't cheat each other there's a
kind of broker ref that would be the
eBay company and most of the time and
the same is for Airbnb most of the time
you don't get murdered most of the time
even on Craigslist you don't get no most
of the time on Craigslist which you
don't get cheated the stories that you
hear in uber they're the exception so
there's a lot of evidence of a great
commercial economy involving a lot of
kindness and respect from fellow men and
a lot of utils to put it in a lot of
benefit to people that is
underappreciated I was thinking of
Reagan's great retort was the creative
society right when Reagan is a very sad
character in this book he loses its job
but you don't get any good roles but he
does give a good speech for Barry
Goldwater yeah and then he decides you
might run for governor of California and
he's what am I gonna call it and he
actually goes to a minister and they
come up with or the minister already has
an offers creative Society which is what
the companies are I do you think the
Intel people when they start in a word
Fairchild did they think they could ever
invent something that would be so useful
no they also believed that everything
you ever did in their area was in
service of government they were stuck in
the military industrial what what do you
build computer parts electronics for the
government only the government can have
a big computer what else would use these
days nobody else would use it and what
they realized and I follow them and you
can see it donning on them and it's like
it's like it is like the Sun coming into
their life is somebody might buy when
I'm making who's not a government and
somebody might buy enough of it that I
would have money for research to invent
something that wouldn't
for government that's the story of Bob
Noyce and Gordon Moore they have a few
epiphanies one is Moore's law which is
you can make smaller chips pretty soon
and there's a kind of geometric
acceleration there but the other is Wow
big companies that make technical things
in stem actually serve regular people
and there's a tremendous relief at that
discovery and breakin doesn't really get
it the only sort it gets it but he has
an intuitive appreciation for the
entrepreneurial because to be an actor
you have to be entrepreneurial you have
a lot of humiliation a lot of highs a
lot of failure a lot of failure yes sir
to what extent do you credit so I right
now oh wait right here hi sorry the one
extent you credit because going on
parallel to the the start of the Great
Society is the civil rights movement to
what extent do you credit the fact that
the civil rights movement then now would
largely be seen as a positive use of
federal power over localities in order
to achieve a common good of expanding
civil rights throughout the the nation
as a convincing the mechanism for people
who might otherwise have been cautious
as a society of what the federal
government can do and might have had a
greater trust in their localities the
civil rights seems to rights movement
seems to have to me too reversed the
presumption that the localities were in
fact trustworthy right because only 8%
of people black are registered to vote
in Mississippi a tragedy at the
beginning of it's wrong
needs fixed right therefore we must bus
every kid in every city across the
northern part of America is what you're
describing because the federal
government intervened and some of us
feel rightly with the Civil Rights Act
and then the Voting Rights Act which was
subsequent it had to we gave it license
to intervene everywhere
right policy for all towns yeah of
course I credit it it's a hard call
because something had to happen in the
south if if only 8% of a certain group
are registered to vote I don't know how
to fix that in the book what I say is
the Voting Rights Act and the civil
rights law I I don't think were negative
they were positive but when we began to
move as Johnson did with his 1960 well I
think it's 65 speech at Howard
University where he basically signed up
for affirmative action and something
beyond equality of opportunity moving to
equality of result that was an overstep
because you always disappoint people
when you promise equality of result so
every this is a a wonderful look I'm
thoroughly enjoying it that's the people
the stories that I'm gonna give you the
last point to you what would you like to
add or suggest that we've not talked
about there's I think the thing that
surprised me most in writing this book
was the importance of labor unions labor
unions are hard to understand they have
their own language they have their own
Court
the NLRB you get what is most of the
time most people don't understand what's
going on but what happened basically in
the 60s was the labor unions were the
core of the Democratic Party much more
so than today as many of you know
because of the way our laws have changed
and some restraint and because of the
weakness of our labor unions and they
decided what happened example there was
a big student movement that started at
Port Huron Michigan the Port Huron
Statement is legendary and when I didn't
know till I researched this book was
that Port Huron meeting of Tom Hayden
who became a legendary SDS person and
Michael Harrington and a few others was
essentially made possible by the afl-cio
and the UAW not only that but Hayden was
later paid by the UAW to do the little
mischief he did in Newark New Jersey and
what is tragic and good stories Walter
Reuther the head of the United Auto
Workers I regard as a kind of fool
flawed hero Walter Reuther just thought
well let's have a youth wing
what's wrong with funding youth a lot of
them are going to go to college well
that's more members from my Union maybe
I could have 2 million members instead 1
million in the United Auto Workers and
squeeze out those Teamsters so I'm gonna
put them on a long leash those students
weld their while while I was wild I went
to Russia you know they're wild and look
the other way and hope that if I fund
them and love them and be like their dad
then later they'll come and be loyal to
me and instead what those students did
the students for a Democratic Society
was wild they did ruin the Chicago
Convention was hand the election of 1968
to Walter Reuther zapala it oh so bitter
imagine the Passover scenes mentioned
the family dinners there's a mother just
couldn't believe that the youth would
turn against him he who did so much for
them and his Union and what's very sad
about ruther was he actually died a nod
of disappointment but in one of those
rickety wrong early Learjets he was in a
terrible plane crash going to a kind of
utopian place in Black Lake Michigan
that he had built a retreat for union
workers but it is symbolic because his
dream of a social democratic America
also died at that point so that I didn't
know and I if you come from the Midwest
and are of a certain age you heard
Walter Reuther 's name every night of
your childhood along with the Vietnam
War count right the casualties were and
Walter Reuther said because the unions
were so important so I will say I
learned a lot about them they're not
that complicated they were wrong they
were an example of lovable people trying
to help other people and doing something
that does not have a positive result
okay Emmett it's been great having you
here thank you very much
I have
Hey I have so much enjoyed your work on
your book on Coolidge and working
Coolidge is wonderful but these two
books they've forgotten around there in
the New Deal if you've not read that I
really recommend that's it that and now
this new history the Great Society will
be the contrarian but very important
books on liberalism the 20th century so
thank you very much thank you could you
all for joining us
[Applause]